a lot of you missing the podcast link is
in the bio on every platform or click if
you see a link in here in the team
edited
I just have realized through a bunch of
emails I read this weekend a lot of
y'all
are not subscribed to the podcast on
Spotify or apple or any of the other
platforms and the truth is there's a lot
more depth in the podcast than there is
in the social platforms so a little
reminder if you are not subbed for the
podcast get your ass in gear when you're
uh walking the dog or sitting in traffic
or like that it's a good little
listen on the treadmill it's a good
little listen I hope you're enjoying it
please everyone who sees this leave a
comment if you are a podcast listener
and explain to the others the value
you're getting from it podcast like get
on it